نيمار يسرب محادثات سريه مع لاعبي المنتخب
البرازيلي لعب بذراع مكسوره امام المغرب
صور اشرف حكيمي وزوجته تشغل السوشال ميديا
هذه الاخبار وغيرها تتابعونها على العربيه
والعربيه بمتابعتكم
[موسيقى]
نبدا واخبارنا مع البرازيلي نيمار الذي
فاز الزمالك
حوارات خاصه بهم عبر حسابه على الانستغرام
بدون الحصول على اذن ثلاثي حتى يوضح
للجماهير البرازيل كيف كان اللاعبون
يرغبون في حصد
ومع المونديال نبقى حيث كشفت التقارير
واعلاميه ان البرتغالي في بي ان هام
مباراه منتخبه بلاده امام المغرب بكسر في
ذراعه الصحف البرتغاليه اكدت ان المدافع
المخضرم خضع لفحوصات طبيه اظهرت اصابته
بكسرا في ذراعه اليسرى واصيب ابن تاسعه 39
عاما في الدقيقه 51 في المباراه حيث ظهر
فيها ممسكا بيده من الالم
شغل اشرف حكيمي وزوجته مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه
بصوره لهما بالابيض والاسود صور ثنائي
التي اعيد انشرها تصدر بها غلاف مجلات فوق
العربيه لشهر اكتوبر الماضي وذلك قبل نحو
شهر من انطلاق المنافسات المونديال التي
يشارك فيها حكيم مع المنتخب المغربي وكما
نرى في الصور ارتدى حكيمي بدله توكسيد
سوداء اللون من دون قميص ام هبه فرتدات
ابيض
الختام مع القط طال ديب الذي لوحده مودع
مودعا قطر ومتجعا الى انجلترا بعدما تبناه
ثنائي مانشستر سيتي كار ووكر وجونسونس
اللاعبان اصطحب القط بعدما تعرف عليه في
مقر تدريبات المنتخب الانجليزي في الدوحه
ومن المقرر ايقضي القط اربعه اشهر في حجر
الصحي قبل ان ينضم مجددا الى ثنائي
[موسيقى]